[Music]
foreign
spoilers show I'm your host Paul and
after our breakdown of Terminator 2 I
promised I'd be back with another big
Arnie movie this week you have decided
to tackle the Sci-Fi Action film
Predator which is easily one of the best
movies from the 80s like a lot of
Barney's early action films the movie's
a classic and in this video we're gonna
be breaking it all down this includes
Easter eggs hidden details and also the
making of trivia that shows how good
this movie really is because some damn
fool accused you of being the best
now weirdly the idea for predator was
actually inspired by Rocky and a joke
that one of the writers overheard the
punchline was that after Rocky IV Balboa
had beat the Russians and had no one
else that he could fight all that was
left was aliens and after a rocky vs ET
joke this inspired screenwriter Brothers
Jim and John Thomas to go make the movie
although they didn't necessarily lean
into the rocky thing they clearly took
ideas from Rambo and in my research I
actually expected to come across some
stuff on sliced alone him and Ani had a
big rivalry at the time but
unfortunately Sly fighting ET something
we're just gonna have to imagine now
there's also some Urban myths centered
around aliens that do somewhat have
their roots in reality it has been
rumored this film only got put into
production cause James Cameron's classic
had been so well received would be years
before Alien 3 got put into production
and this 20th Century Fox wanted to get
something out in the downtime according
to the rumors this is why Predator got
Green Layer but it was actually in
production during 1985 this was a whole
year before aliens release but it has to
be said that the success of it pushed
the film further along originally titled
Hunter the first draft centered around a
group of alien hunters made up of
various species that all had various
goals it was basically a safari trip to
Earth with the focus on the creatures
before things were reworked to Center on
a soul Hunter this would be tackling the
most dangerous game in the universe
which was going to be shown to be man
that's right yeah most dangerous game in
the universe I'll spoil Avengers end
game two days before it releases don't
you worry about it now originally there
was only gonna be one Target and this
would be a Native American character
which is kinda poignant looking back as
we know the lead would be reworked into
Arnie and the Native American character
would then morph into Billy however why
I'm saying it's poignant is because
decades later we get the prey prequel
which would of course center around a
Native American character battling the
Beast now when Annie came in he
suggested that they send her around a
team of crack Commandos because he
wanted to make a film like the
Magnificent and seven over time the
script was reworked several times with
them eventually ending up with what we
got in the end this would culminate with
the elements of the modern world being
Stripped Away so that all that was left
were primitive weapons come the end of
the film The Hunter becomes the hunted
and I've always loved how the Dynamics
of this movie flip for the end
foreign
ER is of course one of the most iconic
creatures of all time and it stands out
for a number of reasons designed by Stan
Winston it's about who's meant to
resemble a tarantula and its skin also
shares similar properties to Locust
however it wasn't always this way and
had they stuck with the original design
then the iconic creature would have
looked totally different the first
design was Far More insect-like in its
appearance with only describing it as a
bug with a duck's head as Jean-Claude
Van Damme was actually brought into play
the role and this is because he was seen
as someone who could bring agility to
the performance if you've ever watched
the behind the scenes stuff then you've
probably seen some of the footage with
him and the actor actually shot several
key scenes this included the moment in
which he killed Dylan and Van Damme's
been pictured alongside cold weathers
several times on set there's also a shot
where a bright red version of it races
through the jungle and this was a
technique that they used to create the
cloak the bright red was used because it
was the exact opposite of the green of
the Jungle and the blue that you got in
the clear skies the creative team would
come in and film two takes with a suit
running through one whilst it was absent
in the other the one with it missing
would be filmed with a wider lens and
thus a vague outline of the alien could
be seen with a footage bending around it
using chroma key techniques they then
dropped the red suit out and what we got
in the end was the brilliant cloak
effect and that of course made it to the
film but what didn't was Jean-Claude Van
Damme complaining that the suit was too
difficult to move around in they then
brought in Stan Winston to redesign the
character this new version was eight and
a half feet tall with Kevin Peter Hall
now in the role it was extremely
difficult to move around in still and
they often had to use a bungee rig and
other tricks to keep it in place the
suit was so heavy that the tree at the
end is actually made out of concrete and
this is because a real one wouldn't
support the weight all had a nightmare
on set the guy was constantly worn out
but as a thank you director John
tiermann ended up including him in the
movie at the end Dutch is picked up by a
chopper and the pilot of this is none
other than the actor
sadly he passed away in 1991 and this
was after he contracted HIV from a blood
transfusion all died a month short of
his 36th birthday but his performance
will live on forever in this and Harry
in the Hendersons now for iconic as the
Predator is I don't think the movie
would have been as big of a success
without its core cast if you've been
following our aliens retrospective then
you know how much we talk about how
important the side characters are in a
film like Alien 3 when almost all the
characters looking act the same it's
difficult as an audience to get attached
to them other films like alien and
aliens have several memorable cast
members so when you're watching them get
taken out you actually feel something
that's when I feel like the case is with
predator and all these characters
definitely Stand Out Rick tinan really
wanted them to build up some camaraderie
and he actually had the cast training
together for weeks before they started
shooting beginning at 6am they'd run
through Fitness and firing regimes that
made them all come together as one
cohesive unit however as I'm sure you
can guess the these guys had let's say
some friendly competition that led to
some hilarious stuff happening on set
when you got a guys wouldn't miss the
universe several times people are
obviously going to want to try now do
them on screen and look the most Macho
in this movie of Macho men everyone was
getting a belly to work out before going
to set and Carl Weathers has talked
about some of the stuff they got up to
he said that Jesse Ventura would arrive
15 minutes before Arnie and he'd pour a
bottle of water over himself as he was
coming in this made only think that he'd
been sweating due to waking up hours and
the Sony start arriving earlier in order
to try and beat him well this got in on
this too and he said that it got to a
point where they were working out at 3am
however weather is said that he'd act
like his physique was given to him
naturally and he'd work out away from
all the actors so they couldn't see a
Ventura yeah he was over the moon after
learning from the Wardrobe Department
that his arms were bigger than anise
delighted he suggested to the actor that
they have an arm measuring contest and
the winner of this would get a bottle of
champagne and of course the loser would
be embarrassed however jira lost because
it turned out that Arnie had told the
Wardrobe Department to tell him that his
homes were bigger I think when you see
the characters you can kind of feel this
camaraderie leaping off the screen and
it helps to make the character so
memorable now one thing I actually
forgot until doing this breakdown was
that the movie begins with a shot of the
ship coming into Earth akin to the
opening of the thing this teases what's
to come and it instantly lets us know
that the movie's about an alien now when
talking about this movie A lot of those
are sparked too completely forgot this
is how it opens up and we question
whether it kind of spoiled a mystery
that this movie centers around this is
something the creative team apparently
wrestled over two but ultimately in the
end they settled on keeping it I think
without it you just have no idea what
the Predator is when the movie finished
so this at least gives you an idea of
what's going on anyway from here we go
to the crew coming in and watch them
getting off the chopper everyone's got
their own luck Barney's easily given the
best intro of them all sitting in the
seat we watch him sparking up a cigar
and this is something actors smoke
throughout his entire life Carl Weathers
actually blames only for getting him
hooked on them as he gifted him a box on
set and never looked back either way
he's the portrait of masculinity and it
cements a tone that they're going to be
going for however because of health and
safety Arnie wasn't just allowed to
spark one up inside a helicopter so the
Flames we see were actually added in
post-production now only it was
obviously coming off the back of
Commando and the similarities actually
go just beyond the tone the movie has
the fictional South American country and
I call Valverde which is also summing up
pops up in this film mctiernan would
also go on to direct several films in
the die-hard franchise too and those
films contain a mention of it as well so
technically yeah they're all in the same
universe so mixed here and intend to do
little things that connect all his
movies a bit off track yeah yeah but die
hard as John McLean coming off a plane
bring his wife a giant teddy bear
unwrapped around it is a big red bow in
the hunt for the Red October we end with
Jack Ryan boarding a plane and he also
takes a teddy bear with a red bow around
it save that for our die-hard breakdown
but we watch as Dutch arrives to learn
about the mission a helicopter carrying
a cabinet minister has apparently gone
down Behind Enemy Lines though as we
learn there is more to it now
interestingly the person they're trying
to find is called Jim Hopper which is
the name of the character David Harbor
plays in stranger things Shane Black's
character is also called Hawkins and
potentially they use both of these to
influence the show either way at this
point we're introduced to Dylan now we
get what's one of my most favorite
moments in film you son of a
I love how the handshake sort of changes
into an arm wrestle and it shows how
competitive that Dutch really is it also
solidifies the idea that he's the best
and it makes sense why the Predator
views him as an equal now the way the
mission is pitched is that it's played
as a rescue mission which is the only
way that they would have got Dutch on
board this is actually hinted to us
earlier in the scene when Dylan asks why
Dutch didn't help out when they were in
Libya good old days yeah like the good
old days then how come you passed on
Libya huh oh that wasn't my style come
on why'd you pass we Rescue Team not
assassins so we get the idea that Marley
is upright and that his team also works
alone
Channel my team always works alone
you know that they actually gave a
little note to this in the credits and
the entire crew's name will appear in
one block together this is because yet
they work alone and these credits also
contain a detail that ties back to the
group in that we can catch shame black
reading a copy of Sergeant Rock which
was used as the basis to influence the
Commandos this was a comic that Ani was
actually planning on adapting and he
brought several of them to the set to
read during the downtime as we know that
never got made but at least it's still
got a place appearing in this movie a
shame black was brought in to do
rewrites of the dialogue and he'd get
his own chance at a predator film
decades later Shane black was behind the
Predator but yeah the last the less said
about that the better anyway we watch as
the Choppers fly in and hear the song
Long Tall Sally by Little Richard
[Applause]
this song actually appears later on in
the film and Max sings it at one point
[Music]
I love the red light filter that they
have yeah and it could be used as a way
to foreshadow the bloodshare that the
crew are about to face this moment with
the helicopters of course mirrors
Vietnam and we learned that both Dylan
and Dutch were deployed there during
1979. no more respect still in though
because he's got a desk job and we see
how the crew instantly sets him out
dropping in they scout out the area and
eventually come across a collection of
skin corpses we will have to blur this
because of YouTube but if you've seen
the film then you'll know all their
skulls are intact later on though the
Predator adds the cruise to his
collection and he didn't bother with
these guys because he didn't see them as
equals instead it's a calling card a
signal the Hanson and the Predator
actually acts a lot like a hunter
hunters will tend to survey and stalk
their price silently and they'll fool
them until they get the perfect shot
there's also the equipment he uses and
Hunters sometimes use wooden pipes to
mimic a duck call
I kind of feel like this is why the
Predator uses Billy's laugh and it lines
up with how Hunters act in real life now
Billy finds bullet casings any guesses
that the Green Berets were firing Wally
into the jungle this is something that
the characters later do because as we
know they can't see the Predator they're
clearly panicked and just firing at
random man I feel like this gets flipped
come the final act when Dutch makes
himself invisible through using mud he
manages to get the upper hand and he
lands a devastating blow this course is
the Predator to start firing randomly
and it shows just how much the roles
have reversed at this point blame breaks
out his minigun and this is actually
something that we've seen in our
breakdowns before have you watched our
Terminator 2-1 then you'll know how he
talked about the one there being a
similar model to what's shown in this
movie although it actually goes beyond
that I I learned something myself and
this is the exact same gun that's used
in both films it's also at this point
that we get the Predator's Vision now we
can see things from its point of view in
this movie we only get the film infrared
ones but the sequels show it has more
than just these two however Reddit user
x-ray girl127 pointed out that you do
get other hints towards it having a
remote you wouldn't be able to avoid the
tripwires without having additional ones
unless there has to be more on top of
what we get now just in the same way
that it observes them before striking we
see his Dutch also does this too spying
on the camp they make a plan and we get
a big bombastic over the top scene
played out like a classic action movie
this shows us exactly how good these
guys are stick around and Arnie actually
improvised this line which I think shows
you know that they're just they're
Hamming it up now in the lead-up to it
they come across a Claymore Mine which
Blain nearly triggers however we watch
as they stop and disarm it ever
resourceful they actually use his mind
later at roughly the one hour minute
Mark and the one they planned for the
Predator is the exact same mine you can
tell it's because Max sticks a twig in
the top of it which he later pulls out
when they're setting up a trap Dutch
also pushes a truck in which confuses is
the enemy and it allows the group to
strike whilst they're unaware of what's
happening now these are the tactics the
Predator uses too with confusion in the
element of surprise being a prime weapon
none of the rebels ever had a chance and
we later learn this is why the group is
called in turns out they were actually
brought in to stop a soviet-backed
Invasion and the Green Berets from
before were actually on the same Mission
the cabinet minister was really CIA and
the paranoid arises for what's going on
you get the feeling that we don't know
what's happening and this is heightened
by whatever's in the jungle I love how
there's almost this superstitious
element to it and the Predator could
easily be seen as a ghost it's an
apparition a personification of death
and we'll talk about the symbolism
behind this later in the video capturing
a rebel named Anna they head for the
Border as the area is too hot for the
helicopters to land now speaking of a
different kind of here we of course have
the jungle itself and what we learn
about the predator species it said that
they come during the hottest years and
then around office Story the Elders of a
village used to tell the children
when I was little we found a man
he looked like
like budget
is
in the hottest years this happens
means the demon who makes trophies of
man seen as a demon we know in hindsight
that the Predators come from a hot
planet and they've started visiting us
more and more due to the Earth heating
up our Duke saves Dylan by killing a
scorpion on his back and I was wondering
if this was reverse symbolism from
backstabbing them probably a reach but
the Predator lighter picks us up and
studies there and I'd like to think this
identifies a scorpion as a predator and
this is why the group become even more
elevated and stairs the Hawkins tells
Billy a jug which makes him burst out
laughing and this is what the Predator
ends up recording
oh
it actually plays his back very very
faintly and this is what tips Billy off
that summing might be watching them
[Music]
this is what the creature of course also
uses at the end Nana plays it back after
setting up the self-destruct and
suddenly landham who played Billy was
Infamous for his short temper and he was
Notorious for getting in fights on set
when people wouldn't hit the Thumbs Up
Button the studio actually had to hire a
bodyguard for him whose sole purpose was
to protect other people from him now as
they move further in we can clearly
sense that something soft before this
video I I of course knew all this stuff
with Van Damme and I was thinking like
they must have had to reshoot so much of
the movie just due to the suit change
how about when you re-watch it you don't
actually see the Predator that merch and
outside of the third act the costumes
barely in it instead we get long shots
at nothing other than the jungle and I
love how this gets you to also look
about the scene to see if you can make
it out also just this bit was killing me
laughing a bit oh look there's a part
where only just walks in holding a
massive machine gun at a perfect right
angle and this is solely just to make
his bicep pop out even more no way is
that anyway hold the gun like that you
would never be trying to do that but my
man's done it because he's that
hard and during these moments we also
get a snake creeping in and these
animals can also sense infrared just
like the Predator now Anna makes a break
for it which is when the Predator
attacks and we get the iconic sort of
rattlesnake clicking
foreign
if you listen closely you can actually
hear this very early on in the movie and
it happens just before they discover the
skin bodies
later on we actually hear the creature's
voice and this was portrayed by Peter
culley
in case you don't know he also voiced
Optimus Prime and I love how you can
kind of hear the similarities in the
performance he was the one who developed
the clicking sound because he said the
Predator's face reminded him of a Dying
crab anyway Blaine shot two with a
predator attacking from the trees and in
a nice nice carryover we see he's
wearing an MTV t-shirt not a massive
detail but when we saw him getting off
the chopper he was wearing it at the
start I appreciate the continuity in the
costume department now the blast comes
from the Predator's shoulder Garden
which was named the parrot gun by the
creative team Mack actually gets a look
at it and its eyes glow gold just before
it runs off this was done to mimic the
eyes of a cat which of course to some is
a predator too mainly if you're a mouse
yeah but it leads to them just firing
into the jungle blood is found which
lets him know can be killed and this was
made through using the liquid from
inside glow sticks now that night we cut
the macro menacing over the good times
he had with Blaine and he's clearly been
affected heavily by his death a wild
ball leaps out in attack ask them and
aftermath kills it we get a really cool
detail I think you could have found
something bigger
where's the girl now what you're seeing
closely again and see if you notice
anything I think you could have found
something bigger
you
where's the girl so in it we can hear
Billy's laugh but he's not on screen
when this is going on when we cut back
to the group none of them are laughing
either and I think this is actually the
Predator mocking Mac I think you could
have found something bigger
you
where's the girl it turns out this was a
distraction to take Blaine's body and it
tips them off that it's acting like a
hunter searching for its trophies they
try and even the odds by setting up
their own traps and as we wait we see
Mack shaving his head this was
improvised by Bel Duke and they quickly
scrambled to put some fake blood onto it
and we can see this when we get the nice
cut away and then cut back to see it
bleeding I love the shot where we think
Dutch might have it in its sights but it
turns out it's actually sneaking up
behind him again in panic it fires off
randomly but this sets off one of the
traps which then hinges Poncho Mac runs
to Avengers friend's death and Dylan
rushes after him which in some ways
helps to redeem the character of course
that was him because he saved him from
the Scorpion before but eventually this
leads to both the character's deaths I
feel like the Predator uses its
recording Tech once more as we hear Max
say a line which then gets repeated
over here
over here the max had his turn into
lasagna and the characters shot directly
through the skull later on when the
Predator is cleaning its trophy we can
actually see his skull and tell that
it's his due to the big hole in the
middle of it now Rob Ager has done a
fantastic breakdown of just this scene
that you should definitely check out
right after this I don't want to just
copy the whole thing and it's about
eight minutes long but it talks about
the techniques that are applied here it
starts off with what's known as a
farewell look between Dutch and the
character that's often used as a way to
set up their death as he sneaks through
the leaves we watches the camera
somewhat stalks him and it even brushes
the leaves out the way making us feel
like it's been hunting him he's a
character who's been in denial the
entire movie but the close Zoom to his
face comes in as he has a moment of
realization looking back at him is Max
Stone Cold eyes which Rob said
represents the face of death it then
mimics Max voice from when he saved him
from the Scorpion and this makes him
spin around just like the scene from
before
foreign
thanks
anytime anytime anytime
we watch as Dylan looks through the
jungle and you can actually catch the
Predator just before he does we get a
wide shot where we can see it standing
on a branch and it then cuts to Dylan
who at first misses it he then looks
back which is when he spots it but I got
it before you mate and you deserve to
die now when Dylan's arms blown off you
can see the white out which allows the
beam to travel to it directly bit of bit
of well we'll see we'll see in the wires
there and I feel like a dick for pointed
out but I'd get comments if I didn't
either way it leads to Billy's death and
the Predator picks off Poncho leaving
just Dutch and Anna we get the infamous
line
[Music]
which Ani's actually said is his
favorite catchphrase going over the
waterfall we see as he swims in and the
giant tree can be seen which becomes
part of the action later on Dutch gets
to the Shore by the Predator still
stalks him and it's at this point we see
the creature in all its Glory the water
damages the cloak and it lets Dutch know
that there are actually ways that you
can force it to appear now it's also
with this that he discovers the mud
masks his Heat Signature which means
that he now has a way that he can go
invisible this is a weapon he's now got
the power to take it on and he spends a
day setting up traps to take it in the
night Home Alone eat your heart out and
Dutch is now here to show who's the king
of the hunt
foreign
ER Heats its blades too and Mac also
uses fire as a way to draw its attention
it of course sees in heat vision so it
will constantly be drawn to this and
what we get an excellent Showdown that
happens between the pair there's clear
nods to Apocalypse Now and it devolves
into an almost animalistic battle played
out amongst the Wilderness everything
about the movie feels so stripped down
now and and totally it's completely
opposite to the opening act of the film
there's barely any dialogue at all and
all the bombastic and over-the-top
bravado has been Stripped Away to tell a
more centralized cerebral story this
movie would massively influence the
action films that followed it and when
analyzing it for this video I actually
realize this could be seen as a turning
point in the genre the Eddies are of
course completely over the top when it
came with their Heroes but the 90s
changed things up and started playing
more with the Everyman who was a quick
thinker John McLean would of course come
to embody this but the tonal shift can
be seen in this movie too we start off
with a big send-off of the 80s
catchphrase heavy bombs but head towards
more personal and grounded battles that
don't have much dialogue now the
Predator actually best Dutch and he has
him at his Mercy but due to honor and
him actually providing a fight he
decides to go hand to hand after
revealing his face it's such an iconic
and masking scene and the focus on the
mandibles really elevates the character
talked earlier about Stan Winston coming
up with the idea for the the main alien
but apparently it was James Cameron who
added this bit in according to the
Legends anyway we watched the bidding
Through The Eyes Of The Predator and
it's clear Dutch isn't really a match
for him physically however he has his
carefully laid traps which will allow
Dutch to smash him like it's the like
button do it do it come on come on kill
me I'm here come here do it come on
smash the like button of us I'll ask
twice and I'll do it now the Predator
avoids the first trap but Dutch's backup
plan ends up being the one that works
Dutch had one last trick of his sleeve
but unfortunately for him the predated
too we get the iconic countdown scene
with a predator playing out Billy's
laugh and Dutch runs for his life as he
tries to escape the blast
[Music]
now I have seen people saying that
there's no way Dutch could have survived
a nuke and in the second film we learn
how big the blast was according to that
it destroyed 25 kilometers worth of
terrain so you're probably thinking how
did he get out of this well there's
actually a lot of things that people
misinterpret about the ending and most
thing that the Predators are so looser
when it's actually not the case if he
was then he would have just set the bomb
off without a countdown because why even
give the guy time to escape if you just
want him to die along with you as we see
the explosion starting up we can see
that electricity lights at the forest
this shows that it's not necessarily A
Fuller nuke and that it has electrical
properties too won't get any emps or
anything like that because a whole
different subject but yeah it's not
really a typical blast and there are
more more of a focus on electricity now
the PS2 game Predator Urban Jungle
explained this explosion was more
designed to wipe out the Predator's ship
and all evidence of its existence
there's also a brilliant post on Reddit
by user ghost w your mom that actually
explains a lot of the scene and I think
when we go over it you might start to
see the movies ending in a different
light now Predators have an honor
culture similar to the Vikings where
they seek seek to die in glorious battle
to get into Valhalla the Predator is
rightfully beaten in combat and then
Dutch comes in over the top to deliver
the killing blow however as you see
Dutch begins to hesitate he's
potentially gonna show the alien mercy
and spare him which will rob him of his
earned honorable death so the next best
thing to do is go out in a self-imposed
blaze of glory rather than just simply
dying and bleeding out on the floor he
knows that he could kill Dutch with the
touch of a button but that would make
him a sore loser so he sets off the
self-destruct the Predators can set the
yield of their self-destruct system and
he clearly didn't turn it up to 11 but
rather gave Dutch enough that he could
realistically get enough distance
between himself and the eventual
explosion as for the Billy laugh this
comes across like the Predator's mocking
Dutch and thinking that he's gonna die
however the Predator isn't really doing
a last laugh and it's just playing back
the only way that it actually knows how
to convey something in his language it's
not an actual laugh per se and rather
it's playing back Billy's lap because
it's one of the recordings that it
picked up so yeah huge shout out to them
they're coming to a bigger but that's me
just cherry picking the main points of
it let me know if you agree with that or
not but it does kind of reframe the
ending and how it plays out either way
we end with Dutch being rescued and
taking out in a similar manner to how he
arrived it's a complete tunnel shift to
them coming in at the start though and
it perfectly reflects the hell that he's
just gone through now we end with the
credits which include the cast smiling
and giving a little nod to the audience
this is supposed to be a homage to all
the war films like The Dirty Dozen the
Great Escape and it became a staple of
the genre that just helped to Define it
those would have full credit scenes in
them with names and it's something that
the older movies adopted as an evolution
of the curtain core the actors would
come out at the end and give a bow and
in war movies they were used to give the
idea that everyone was part of a brother
hood kind of funny how everyone filmed
their own bit for this section except
Donnie who they just reused footage for
he's the only one who doesn't smile but
I can't find anywhere why this was the
case and have no idea why it happened if
you know then let me know below and that
wraps a predator clocking in at a body
count of 69 humans one scorpion one ball
and one Predator we now have one of the
best action movies of all time going
back to it made it really opened my eyes
to how much you changed things and it's
up there as being one of the big reasons
that Ani would become the highest paid
actor of all time at one point in the
90s though people often criticize his
acting abilities he definitely put his
heart and soul into this and even
sacrificed a lot of his own personal
life to get this movie made only
actually married Maria Shriver during
production with him leaving on a Friday
and returning back to work on the
Wednesday to get the ball rolling guy
apparently was gonna have a honeymoon
but his wife could tell he was
distracted and she said just go make the
movie and we got what we got all in all
the work at that comes through and what
we get is a film that hits on every
level it's got a great memorable
Supporting Cast an unforgettable villain
and a film that evolves and changes over
time it leaves us with what's an
incredible movie and I hope that you've
enjoyed the breakdown on it too if you
did we again we'd appreciate the thumbs
up and make sure you subscribe for
videos like this almost every day you
want to be extra generous and you can
click the join button and support the
channel for the price of less than a can
of coke at your local chippy as a thank
you you'll get to see videos like this
before everyone else does and it makes a
massive difference in keeping us
independent and yeah just helping out
with everything we really really
appreciate it and if you want something
else to watch then definitely check out
our Brighton of Terminator and
Terminator 2 which will be linked on
screen right now you've had some
copyright issues with it and Studio
Canal won't let us use footage of
Terminator 2 in Europe however we've
disputed it but this it's a bit all over
the place and kind of going back and
forth if you want to watch it though
you'll have to visit through using a VPN
connection connected to America uh so
sorry for all the Hoops on that but yeah
we are trying to sort it out anyway
thank you for your patience and
hopefully I'll see you all about another
video soon by the way I've been Paul
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace